less than two years ago this apartment
was on the market the asking price is 26
million dollars now it is 35 million
dollars how does an apartment in a
building that nobody has moved in to go
up ten million dollars in less than two
years right well I think first of all
you know when you're pricing when you're
doing your initial pricing and you need
to sell 145 units you're pricing it for
the sale of that number of units I think
as you sell down your units and you end
up with a couple of units at the end the
combination of more scarcity at that
level but also an improving market would
account for the change I'm really just
stunned by the number of skyscraper
towers residential towers going up in
New York City with luxury apartments
north of 30 million dollars are there
really how strong is the market in the
30 million dollar up apartment and who
are buying these apartments right you
know I think you have to look at
different sub markets I think in in art
property it was really mostly Americans
us locals in in many cases it was New
York locals who want to do if you are in
Tribeca you wanted to be in a property
that had views and had amenities which
were unusual for Tribeca I think there
is a small amount in our property of
foreign nationals from from different
countries I think a lot of these other
properties and it depends on what sub
market you're in I think a lot of the
properties in Midtown or Central Park
south probably have a heavier emphasis
on foreign buyers but I think the
question you're asking will find out
over time whether there is enough demand
or like 157 G's are you still looking at
exposure in New York City or do you feel
like the market stopping you know we've
just made a recent commitment to a
property on 22nd Street we think in the
right sub market we can still do well
there you know we do talk about foreign
demand for apartments in New York cities
particularly luxury apartments how much
in your business do you watch events
abroad in anticipation of it affecting
your market you know I think we think
about that I think we think what's going
on with the stronger dollar what impact
that might have we look at what's
happening in the oil countries and and
the and the flow of funds a lot of the
real estate market is driven today by
flow of funds and I think those two
issues are really important Disneyworld
for seasons we did the story yesterday
showing that the price of admission to
the
Magic Kingdom is above $100 the first
time ever
why Disneyworld why Florida why Orlando
well you know I think that one it was a
combination of an unusual asset for
seasons had this property tied up for a
number of years and we were able to come
in after that period of time also you
know if you look at what happened during
the financial crisis in Orlando the
properties outside of Disneyworld
had revenues dropped by 40% actually the
properties inside the park only went
down 5% so we think that the idea of
being inside the park created a
defensive posture for the property that
that attracted us Soudan what people
don't know about you you spent a lot of
time worrying about this island of
Manhattan in the five boroughs of New
York City in 1979 there was a photo from
prep for prep of a bunch of black girls
and barely in Dalton sweatshirts and it
was just unbelievable how original prep
for prepped was is a program to motivate
black kids to reach in education give us
an update and we're prepped for prep
stands right now you know it's been
spectacularly successful I think right
absolutely and that's how we got
involved as we as we watched our kids in
the private schools and we saw the prep
kids and the prep kids were really one
there were great achievers but they also
made an impact on the classes where our
kids were involved and and today I think
prep is affected over 3,000 kids really
change their lives and actually it's
also part of something called Smart
connections with other programs like
prep which I think have affected 300,000
kids quickly how do you respond to
somebody that says the minorities are
pushing out white kids from educational
opportunities today I think it was a
great at least what I saw in our kids
class and sounds like the same thing
happen too clearly for you is the kids
really improve the educational
experience but the kids who are there
okay well congratulations on that